there are dozens of fainting goat videos
on the web but we wanted to find the
nerve center of the fainting goat world
which as it turns out is in Florida
meets Terry lanai of the International
fainting goat Association she knows
exactly how to make a goat faint what
usually triggers the fainting is when
they're startled or even excited they
will faint you know they'll fall over or
stiffen up when we feed them in the
morning they get excited and also we've
seen the Bucks faint during mating
seasons I think is the adrenaline rush
of sex gets them I guess typical guy
there's a good one
Gabo and it's confusing because they
don't actually faint they're fully
conscious it doesn't hurt them at all
they stay down for maybe ten or fifteen
seconds and they can hear they can see
ah great fun for humans but what exactly
makes these goats do a full-on faceplant
fainting goats have the condition
myotonia congenita it's a genetic
condition affecting a particular gene
telling muscles to tense and to reset to
relax again afterwards normally they
relax instantly and we're able to flee
or fight whatever we choose to do to
defend ourselves in this case the
signals from the brain are sending
through the message to tencel the
muscles but because of this genetic
condition the signals telling the
muscles to relax again on getting
through and so it tenses up can't run
away I've also booked some farmers used
to use these myotonic goats as decoys if
a wolf or some other predator were to
attack the herd of course the myotonic
goat is going to go down and that's
what's going to take the Predators
attention away from the rest of the herd
that's not very nice
and because all mammals muscles have
similar chemistry many species including
us are prone to myotonia congenita by
the mere thoughts enough to stop you in
your tracks